Speaker 1: So I'm going to talk about a lot
on my channel is the existential threat that
white supremacists play in America, the threat
that they pose? Tucker Carlson being chief
among them. I rather famously, if I was famous,
I call him a little cute names, a little pet
names. And I really do believe he is a a googly
eyed feather duster. He has a haircut. He
is a trust fund goon. He is a soft skinned,
smooth brained clown. But he also holds a
position within the American Zygi that is
is an undeniable. He hosts the the most popular
cable news show in all of cable news history.
The most popular show on Fox News right now
by far, and their most popular ever, Hannity's
ratings don't hold a candle to Tucker Carlson's
Bill O'Reilly in his heyday. Nowhere near
Tucker Carlson's. And they keep him around
even though he is just draining on their budgets.
Because who advertises for Tucker Carlson?
No blue chip companies. Up until a few weeks
ago, it was just the my pillow guy and a few
others. But Tucker Carlson is is advancing,
he has tossed away the dog whistle and he
is advancing the conspiracy theory, the racist
conspiracy theory of the great replacement
theory of white genocide, which used to be
talked about only in literal white supremacist
circles, like at neo-Nazi camps and Aryan
Nation up in northern Idaho on my home state.
And he has taken it to prime time, he has
taken it to the morning shows, which is what
I want to talk about today. He went to Fox
News, Fox, Fox and Friends, you know, the
friends over at Fox and Friends and was extolling
the virtues of the great replacement theory
and believes in a conspiratorial fashion that
Joe Biden is trying to destroy. These are
his words, destroy the country. By changing
the demographics of America, watch this.
Speaker 3: I mean that you know what this
tells you honestly, that what's happening
at the border is not a crisis. A crisis is
a flood in Bangladesh. It's an act of God.
This is an intentional act. This is the administration
bringing felons, violent criminals into our
country on purpose. Why would you do something
like that? Only to destroy it. I mean, there's
there's there's no other explanation for this.
It's not an act of compassion. It's an act
of hostility against the United States in
order to change it forever. I think this is
the greatest scandal of my lifetime. What's
happening on the border right now? Well, absolutely.
Although you've heard Secretary Mayorkas,
Tucker says the strategy is working, which
makes you wonder what is the strategy? Right.
Well, the strategy is to change the demographics
of the country. Now, when you say that they
have a heart attack and they call you names,
but they say it out loud. I mean, they say
it on the floor of the Senate Dick Durbin
did two weeks ago. This country is changing
in a way that benefits the Democratic Party,
more Democratic voters. There's no other upside
in this policy, by the way. It doesn't help
the people coming from around the world. There's
a humanitarian disaster unfolding. Thanks.
The Biden administration, the only beneficiaries.
So the people who run the Democratic Party
and this is an effort to change the country
and we should be honest about it and not be
bullied into silence as they take our country
away and import violent criminals.
Speaker 1: What there is a lot there. There's
a lot there to be sure, not only are is Joe
Biden and this administration purposefully
trying to destroy the country. This is the
greatest scandal in his lifetime. These Republicans
are using a lot of this hyperbolic language
surrounding Joe Biden that it's the worst
of this, the greatest crime, this is the the
greatest scandal of all the scandals of America
in the course of Tucker's 50 years on the
planet. There are many this isn't even a scandal.
But in order to whip his audience into a frenzy
and the larger Fox News audience since he's
on Fox and Friends. He has to use this kind
of language. But to rattle on about changing
demographics, it really does put everything
in perspective during Donald Trump's campaign.
There was a lot of analysis around Make America
Great Again. The campaign slogan. And the
question was asked, will win, when was this
moment that they hearken back to? And it's
it's certainly pre 1950 when schools and American
life were segregated. They hope they pine
for these these these nuggets of history,
this is when they believed America was great,
when white dominance in this country was absolutely
unchecked. And that is the time for which
Tucker Carlson yearns, he wants that again
and the fact that the country's demographics
are naturally changing when you're a beacon
of light and a beacon of hope to the world,
as the Republicans have yammering on about
four years, that's what you get. People come
here for a better situation, a better life
for themselves. And their posterity. But that
scares Tucker Carlson, and he is intending
to scare an audience filled with people who
also yearn for those times. Interesting, though,
that he he has a critique about the word crisis
and then at the very end there, this is a
humanitarian disaster. He wanted so badly
to say crisis, but he couldn't because he
just pooh poohed the word. And then, of course,
the the refrain about taking our country away.
Who's country, Tucker? Is it not also my country,
is it not also people of color, their country?
This is no longer. Safely, a white country.
The the melting pot meme has really been overused,
but it is because it is what we are. We are
a diverse country. Diverse, culturally diverse,
ethnically diverse, racially. Diverse ideologically.
And there are certain ideas that are no longer
welcome, white supremacy being among them.
Tucker Carlson, maybe it is you who is trying
to take away our.